-Fred, you know that we've known
each other almost 20 years.
-That's crazy.
-Does that make any sense?
-It's insane.
-It's wild.
-20 years.
This is your 14th appearance
on our show.
-Yeah, 14.
-I mean, you're the best.
Thank you for coming on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-You know, we know each other
so well, but I was trying
to think of maybe --
is there anything that I don't
know about you? Like,
what don't I know about Fred?
So I was going to ask you some
random questions and just see --
These are questions that
I've never asked you before.
-And I've never heard these.
-You actually haven't.
-Okay.
-Have you ever gotten lost?
-Have I ever gotten lost?
Um, yeah. I had this boat.
And I was like, "I'm just
gonna try to get to England."
-Were you already
on that side of the world?
-No, I was on this side.
I was on this side.
And I just started going.
-A big boat? A large --
-The problem is daytime.
'Cause, like, at night,
you know, the stars,
you can kind of -- Yeah.
And then somewhere
during the day, I just --
-You get loopy.
-Yeah, and I ended up in Quebec.
-Wow. Hey. That's
a beautiful place to end up.
-Yeah. Yeah.
If you could clone yourself,
would you?
-Oh, so, I do get this
all the time.
[ Laughter ]
-This one? If you could
clone yourself, would you?
-Oh.
-So there'd be a couple Freds.
-I would.
I think for, like, you know...
-Parties?
-For parties. [ Laughs ]
-Just show up.
"Fred, you just got --
But you're already here!"
-"I know what you
wanna listen to."
-"Oh, this guy's the best!"
Uh...
Backstage you were telling me
that you don't think
you're good at fighting
on screen.
-Oh, yeah. So...
-Or falling.
-Yeah.
Like, I did this movie
called "The Bubble," right?
-Judd Apatow.
-For Judd Apatow.
And there's this fight scene
I had with David Duchovny
that we really had trainers show
us how to, like, really fight
and make it look real.
-Yeah.
-And then it looked so lame.
Like, when it came --
Like, that was --
The joke was
that it looked lame.
But to me, it felt like
real fighting. I was --
-You were going for it.
-I was going for it.
And I was like,
"This is really good."
-And then when you're done with
the take, everyone's laughing?
-They're laughing, and then that
was the joke of the whole thing,
is that, like,
it was totally lame.
But I feel like I'm --
I really do try my best.
-Yeah.
-But...
-You told me that there's
something that you realize
that you are good at
that you never knew.
-Yes.
-A hidden talent.
I think that I have a talent --
this is, like,
throughout my career --
for peeking around a corner.
[ Laughter ]
Every time I've done anything
where I peek around a corner,
it always works.
People really react to it.
It's so crazy. It's guaranteed.
Like, it just works.
-Well, how did you
find this out?
-Over the years.
I was just like...
"I think whenever I peek..."
I'm going to do it for you.
-Okay. Yeah. Would you mind?
-I'm going to do it.
-Would you mind?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'll say your name?
-Yeah.
-Alright.
-It always works. Watch.
-Okay. It always works.
He's gonna go around a corner.
[ Laughter ]
Ladies and gentlemen,
here is Fred Armisen
peeking around a corner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
That's actually pretty good.
That's actually a very --
That's very good.
I like that. That's very good.
You know, every time you come
on our show, you're very nice,
and I ask you to play the guitar
or do something.
-Yeah.
-And you do musical impressions.
And we just happen
to have a guitar always here
when you're here.
Do you mind?
-Yes, I would like to do that.
-Okay. This is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here you go.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
No, but now it's back there.
-Oh. Sorry. Absolutely.
-So, I'll take this.
-Very good.
-Go this way like this.
-Yep. Okay. Very good.
-Alright.
-Here we go. Here we go.
Okay, so, the first impression
I'm going to do.
This is -- This is
any guitar player on Instagram
in the last two years.
They do this thing
where they put their guitar
up to their face so that, you
know, the phone can pick it up.
So if you can zoom in closer.
There we go.
Yeah. Closer.
This is really gonna --
This is everyone on Instagram.
♪♪
♪ November, November, November ♪
♪ Remember November,
remember November ♪
♪ Remember, remember November ♪
It's like kind of -- Even more.
-Yeah, even zoom in more.
Even up there --
It's almost like a violin.
-Yeah, it's like -- This is it.
-Yeah, it's almost
like a violin.
♪ November, November, November ♪
♪ November, remember November ♪
-Yeah, that's a good one.
That's a nice one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So...can I just say something
to guitar players
just before I start?
Guitar players.
We've got one here.
Whenever you do your D chord...
[ Guitar strums ]
You don't always
have to do this.
[ Plucking notes ]
Alright?
[ Laughter ]
For some reason, as soon
as anyone hits the D...
-That is a brilliant
observation.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh. I totally do that.
That's so funny.
-Okay, so, what I've --
I've done this once on this show
before where I did
guitar strumming styles
from around the world.
-Yeah.
So, just as a recap,
for example, Australia
is minor chords into major
chords but really quickly, so...
♪♪
♪ Don't go around here
anymore, anymore ♪
♪ Don't go around ♪
So that kind of -- Yeah.
Yeah, very -- That's Australia.
England -- So, I'm gonna
just do some other countries.
England is like -- It's like --
[ Imitating syncopated notes ]
It's a very syncopated --
It's like...
♪♪
♪ I saw her by the river bend ♪
♪ A statuesque silhouette ♪
That...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Thank you.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Then Norway.
Norwegians like to play the
guitar as if they're showing you
that they're playing guitar.
So it's sort of like...
[ Singing in foreign language ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
France is kind of, like, very
rolling when they sort of...
[ Singing in French ]
♪♪
Like rolling around like that.
And then Scotland is
right on the quarter notes,
and it's all
minor chords like...
♪♪
♪ It's great to be alive,
it's great to be alive ♪
except you're dead ♪
♪ It's great to be alive,
it's great to be alive ♪
♪ It's great to be alive
unless you're dead ♪
So there's that.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
And then --
And then, like, South America --
Chile, Uruguay, Venezuela,
they really -- they love ska.
Every time I've gone,
it's very sort of...
♪♪
[ Singing in Spanish ]
-Fred Armisen, everybody!
Tickets are on sale now for his
"Comedy for Musicians
but Everyone is Welcome" tour.
We'll be right back
with Chloe Sevigny.
Come on back. Stick around.
♪♪
♪ Get up ♪